this is a production of Cornell
University
started them so I'm going to be talking
to you all today about a project I'm
working on trying to understand how
proteins adapt to high temperatures and
we know that temperature is important
and it affects both Mathieu macro
phenotypes like plant yield and
molecular characteristics of the cell so
for example we know that biochemistry
speeds up at high temperatures cell
membranes become more fluid and protein
structure and Composition adjust as well
because proteins need to maintain more
hydrogen bonds to maintain their
structure and this matters in the
context of plants and plant breeding
because the world is starting to warm up
and as different areas of the world
increase in temperature we're likely to
see a reduction in crop performance and
ideally what we could do is build
genomic selection models to help
breeders be selecting for crops that are
still efficient at these elevated
temperatures but from a protein
perspective this is fairly difficult
there's a number of roadblocks
preventing this us from doing this right
now
and probably the most significant
roadblock is just that we don't actually
understand right now which residues
matter within a protein and because in a
plant there could be thousands if not
millions of sites that actually matter
her protein stability and thermal
adaptation this becomes a fairly
daunting question to look at and that
leads to my research goals which are
actually to use a different system
in my case prokaryotes to be trying to
identify temperature sensitive sites
within the genome and really be
understanding the biochemistry behind
these sites to see what changes are
making proteins thermo tolerant and can
we rank or prioritize these temperature
sensitive sites and ultimately decide
what do we want to incorporate in these
future GS models now I'm doing this in
prokaryotes because they make a really
good system for studying molecular
adaptation there's a number of reasons
for that you can see six of them on the
screen here and I just want to highlight
two of them the first is this extreme
temperature box so we know that
prokaryotes can exist at
degrees Celsius and live and grow every
temperature through and even above 100
degrees Celsius so there's quite a bit
of quite a number of temperatures that
they're able to adapt to and they're
also useful because they tend to have
large effective population sizes and
fairly rapid generation time and that's
important because it means that
selection can act fairly efficiently on
every individual protein to adjust and
optimize its function at that prokaryote
optimal temperature now the other thing
I need to be able to look at protein
adaptation in prokaryotes is an
understanding of how prokaryotes are
growing and what their optimal growth
temperatures are so a lot of you
probably know em ricci men he is a
former postdoc in the buckler lab and he
and I built a model that uses tRNA
sequence from prokaryote genomes and
uses that to predict optimal growth
temperature or OGT and you can see from
this plot here on the left that this
works in both archaea and bacteria and
is fairly accurate and what's really
important about this model is that it
gives us the ability to predict optimal
growth temperature for any new
prokaryotes species we have and really
all we need is a genome to do that the
other thing that's really nice about
this model is that these predictions are
independent of protein composition and
other protein features so I can actually
use these optimal growth temperatures in
my questions looking at protein
adaptation so we're currently in the
process of writing up this paper but for
now I'm using this model to predict
optimal temperatures across almost 5,000
different prokaryotes species and so
that brings me to my current question
about protein adaptation and I have
three main hypotheses that I'm focused
on right now the first is fairly
straightforward
it's just that protein composition is
affected by temperature and I'm actually
not going to get into this in a lot of
detail this is fairly well documented
already and we know that there are some
amino acids that tend to shift and
become more prevalent at high
temperatures so I've checked this in the
data set that I'm working on and what I
see is fairly consistent with the
literature we tend to see more glutamic
acid
and baling and isoleucine and less
glycine so that lets me move on to my
second hypothesis which is that thermal
adaptation is highly polygenic so this
should seem fairly intuitive to you I've
already talked about some of the ways
the temperature affects cell function
and so if temperature is affecting every
protein we would expect to see changes
in just about every protein across the
genome and so to try and get an idea of
which proteins are important or which
residues within those proteins seem to
be adapting to temperature I've
developed a Jewess model to associate
specific protein domain residues with
optimal growth temperature of a
prokaryote and the way I do this is sort
of like this I take a set of species
proteomes from ensembl bacteria and that
includes both bacteria and archaea
species and I identify protein domains
using the pfm protein database and the
hidden Markov models in that database so
for example if I take this blue proteome
I can find three instances of protein
domain one and two instances of protein
domain two then I do a multiple sequence
alignment for all of those domain
observations and I numerically recode
that that protein domain just so that
it's easier to work with a linear
regression and then last I just
associate those residues with optimal
temperature now when I do this I get a
Manhattan plot so on the left here you
see an example Manhattan plot from one
protein domain the x-axis shows
positions in the protein domain
alignment the y-axis is our significance
and that red dotted line is the
bonferroni significance threshold and so
what might pop out to you here is that
there are a number of sites that show up
as significant in this example and
what's kind of fun about this is we can
actually look at the biochemistry and
understand what's going on at specific
sites so for example at this blue site
we see that we can look at amino acid
hydrophilicity and while it's not a
perfect correlation in general we see
that species with higher optimal
temperatures tend to have amino acids at
this site with low hydrophilicity where
species with moderate optimal
temperatures tend to have amino acids
with high hydrophilicity and this makes
a lot of sense and matches our
expectation because we already know that
proteins tend to be less hydrophilic at
high temperatures now when I do this
across all of the protein domains I'm
looking at I see that there are a lot of
domains with a lot of significant sites
essentially most of the domains I've
looked at have enrichments for
temperature associations about 90% of
the archaea domains and about 80% of the
bacteria and on average about a quarter
of each of these protein domains seems
to be a significantly associated with
temperature so that seems to confirm my
second hypothesis essentially thermal
adaptation does seem to be highly
polygenic and on average about a quarter
of the domain of every protein domain
seems to be associated with temperature
and so that brings me to my third
question or hypothesis which is that
genomes have a similar evolutionary
response to temperature and what i mean
by this is that there are likely to be
some key sites that transfer across
phylogenetic groups so I think that
there will be some sites that show up as
important in bacteria but also then end
up being important in archaea and these
sites are particularly interesting
because they're already conserved across
phylogenetic groups and that makes them
good candidates for us when we're
thinking about trying to extend this
model beyond prokaryotes and to
eukaryotes and so that's what I'm
working on right now is really trying to
identify these sites that are
significant across phylogenetic groups
and unfortunately it gets quite
complicated very quickly there are a lot
of sites that show up as significant and
unfortunately a lot of the sites showing
up as significant in archaea are also
significant in bacteria so I've just got
an example of two protein domains here
we have domain 4 and 118 and what I'm
showing you is a blue circle that shows
you how many sites are significant in
bacteria and a red circle that shows you
how many are significant in archaea now
when we overlap these we get that
pinkish purple color and you can see
that
focusing only on the site significant in
both of these phylogenetic groups does
reduce our search space but it still
leaves us with a lot of sites to be
looking at and so we need better ways to
prioritize these sites and unfortunately
the rank correlation between these
overlapping sites is fairly poor and so
we're not able to just prioritize these
sites based on their level of
significance so this third hypothesis is
very much still in progress it's true
that many sites appear significant
across phylogenetic groups but how we're
gonna prioritize these is still fairly
unclear and that brings me back
essentially to the beginning so I have
my research goal is to be identifying
these temperature sensitive protein
residues and I've told you a little bit
about how I've started to do that I'm
continuing now to try and reduce this
search space and predict which residues
are likely to matter and I really want
to be using the underlying biochemistry
to do this and ultimately as I've said
I'd like to be building models that can
transfer across phylogenetic groups
first across bacteria and archaea and
then ultimately to eukaryotes and
hopefully to plant proteins so we can
understand how plant proteins adapt to
temperature as well but that obviously
is not done yet and we'll be hopefully
the subject of a future talk but I'm
about out of time so I will wrap up
quickly say thank you to everybody in
the buckler lab for past and ongoing
conversations on this project and I'm
happy to take questions or comments if
you guys have them thank you Sara while
people are maybe taking some time to
write up some questions in the chat I'm
going to post the evaluation links here
ok and I see that John Luke has asked in
gos you have to control for structure
how do you do that in your adaptation
it's a really good question there's a
couple ways that I've tried to control
for structure so one of the ways is to
build a kinship matrix based on the
camer distance matrix from these species
genomes and another way that I've tried
to control for structure is using pcs on
the domains themselves to try and
account for some of the sequence
similarity within those domains
do either of those work well or change
the outcome
so the using the distance matrix based
on Kaymer frequency doesn't really seem
to change the outcome much using pcs
does seem to change it if I use
information about the sequence directly
does that answer your question I'm not
sure which Nikolas that is Rebecca asks
do I have plans to test kylo si
experimentally I do not any
collaborators in line for that there are
some people that work on directed
evolution in Chlamydomonas which would
be kind of cool but I haven't tried to
set anything up or really thought about
what that would look like John Lee I
think that temperature adaptation is
highly polygenic to answer your question
but I do still want to reduce the number
of low sigh that I'm looking at because
it it would be nice to prioritize the
sites in such a way that we can
um extend this more easily to eukaryotes
if that makes sense I think that there's
going to be a lot of sites changing in
bacteria and archaea because of
phylogeny or be cut for other reasons
that aren't necessarily going to be
interesting in eukaryotes and so
reducing the search space or at least
trying to understand some of the
biochemistry underlying the sites that
show up is significant I think will be
what's really important to extending the
model John Luke asked how many loci do I
ideally want to end up with that's a
good question and I I don't know right
now I'm focusing on transferability
between bacteria and archaea and I
haven't thought very much about sort of
a target number of low-side okay if
there are no further questions thank you
very much though thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu